في بوس منتشر على المنصات في مصر وقالب
الدنيا الفوز لرئيسه المجلس القومي للمراه
مايا مرسي وعنوانه بطله الجمهوريه وبطلت
الشرقيه ومضمون وانقاذ سيده اسمها اماني
محمد لاسره كامله من الغرق الفوساد عمل
ضجه كبيره على من الصوت والناس من بعده
بدات تدور وتبحث عن اماني محمد وسائل
الاعلام طبعا السوشيال يحتفل ببطولتها
وانجازاتها وفيديوهات مقابله تحملت
المنصات وكمان العربيه حتى اللقاء معها
لمعرفه تفاصيل القصه
انت متجه عن طريق المنيا القمح ان كنت
راكبه تورته وقال لي من الابتدائي مفيش اي
مشكله
من الاتجاه الثاني وبعدين لقينا ناس
ملمومه ولقينا العربيه في نص البحر اخذت
بعدي وقمت جايه باسال واحد كان واقف شخص
كان واقف بقول له الله يكون في عون صحاب
العربيه قال لي الله يكون صاحبها ازاي وهو
صاحب العربيه فيها وانت بتتكلم وانا بتهزر
بجد قال لي هي دي فيها حاجه هزار اخذت بعض
طبعا ومسكت حديده من شخص كان واقف
البحر لحد ما وصلت للعربيه
وبعدين
عملت لهم اسعافات اوليه طبعا في ساعه
نزولي اكيد البحر اطفال
ان انا يعني هيحصل ممكن نحطها على بطنهم
لحد ما الميه طلعت واخذت بعد ما يحصل لهم
المستشفى والحمد لله طلعت خيار واهل
الاطفال شكلاتنين
وطلع لي المبلغ من الميه دخلته طبعا
وبعدين برده لما عرف انه ان انا زعلانه
جالي وتاثري همم وقال لي الاسره الكريمه
بكره ان شاء الله
اماني يا سيد عمري 28 سنه من سكان الشرقيه
خاصه بعد ما الاعلام توجه للجهه الرسميه
يستفسر السلطات بدورها نفذ الواقعه تماما
وقالت انه ما في اي بلاغه تقدم بالواقع
اللي بتتكلم عنها اماني وحتى المستشفى
اللي قالت انها تم نقلهم عليها قالوا ما
وصلت اللي عندهم اي حالات لغرق او مصابين
في حادث انقلاب سياره طيله الايام الماضيه
بعدها جاءت عاد روايات الناس اللي في
المنطقه واللي كانت هي كمان صادمه وقالت
انه ما صار شيء من هذا النوع في المنطقه
ابدا ابدا يعني فيلم عالمي من الوزن
الثقيل وفضيحه وعليها شهود تصوير مشاهد
بطوليه من الدرجه الاولى وبعد كل هذا
القصه طلعت مفبركه هو تلقى من خيال اماني
ويعني نقدر نسميها بطله من ورق او من وحيد
الخيال والوهم وما في اي دليل واضح على
انه القصه صارت وحتى الاسره اللي انقذتها
مو مبينه هذا غير تداول اخبار انه في
امراه كمان طلبت منها اماني تشهد انه
الواقعه صارت وتاخذ 100,000 جنيه مقابل
ذلك وعموما حتى ما يا مرسي رئيسه المجلس
القومي للمراه بعد كل هذا المساحه البوست
اللي نشرتها اما الدوافع حتى هذه اللحظه
مجهوله
[موسيقى]